من بيروت معنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياس حنا اهلا وسهلا
ما لفت نظرك في تطورات المعارك الاخيره
عثمان تم الحديث
يجب ان نعي اليوم ان ميليتو بول تبعد
تقريبا 85 كيلو متر عن جبهه زبالوجيا
وبيانس تبعد ما يقارب 120 كم هي الهدف
البعيد المدى ولكن اليوم نحن لا نزال في
المرحله الاولى من هذا
الهجوم المضاد اليوم استعمال الطوافات
بشكل كثيف ومكثف من قبل القوات الروسيه
حتى انه في برديانسك اتت او جلبت روسيه ما
يقارب 20 طوافه مما يسمى بالاليغيتر او
التمساح وهي مهمه جدا وهي التي انزلت بعض
الخسائر في الهجوم الاوكراني
وتحذير
شويغو بعدم قصف
شبه جزيره القرم نحن لا نزال في المرحله
الاولى عثمان
والضبابيه الشامله والكامله لا تزال
بالرغم من تحقيق القوات الاوكرانيه بعض
هي سهام هي نقل المعركه الى ارض الروسيه
اظهار المنظومه الامنيه التي يعتبرها
الرئيس بوتين انها لا تخترق انها مخترقه
نحن نتحدث
مناطق داخل روسيه
ومسيرات هذه ليست المره الاولى فوق
الكرملين وحتى في محيط الكرملين حتى حتى
حسب
مراسل جزيره في دنيا ايضا استهدفت مناطق
داخل دونيتس وكانه اليوم تقصفون المناطق
السكنيه نقصف مناطق سكنيه تقولون عمليه
عسكريه محدوده داخل اوكرانيا لا ستنتقل
الحرب الى الداخل الروسي وهذا من ضمن اذا
صح التعبير الديسبشن او الخداع ولكن
المعركه الاساسيه سهام هي على الجبهه التي
تمتد من حتى كريمينا وحتى
900 كم طول هذه الجبهه
لا اعلم اذا كان بالامكان سياده العميد ان
نسالك عن اذا ما كان الاوكرانيون حققوا
اهدافهم من الهجوم المضاد لان الاهداف لم
تعلن ولكن على الاقل هل يمكن ان نقول ان
هناك مكاسب عسكريه ملحوظه حققوها من خلال
هجومهم المضاد
عثمان المرحله الاولى
هي بروبينج او جاسر نبض على 900 كيلومتر
لايجاد مناطق قابله للخرق اليوم هناك ثلاث
مستويات للقوات الاوكرانيه المستوى الاول
لجس النبض المستوى الثاني لاحداث الخرق
اما العظيم من الجيش الاوكراني المدرعات
وما شابه التي حضرتها مع النيتو والغرب هي
للخرق
والنموغل داخل المنظومه الدفاعيه الروسيه
مع الكثير من المشاكل اهمها عدم التغطيه
الجويه وهذا امر يعاني منه الاوكرانيون
عميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من بيروت شكرا
جزيلا لك